[Music]
hello jails Congress I'm so excited to
be with you this afternoon hopefully you
are refreshed from lunch because we're
going to dive into some really meaty
technical topic right now but first by a
show of hands do you work on a web
application okay great as I expected
almost all of you and that's awesome
because I too work on cool web apps so
at least I think they're cool and that's
how I pay my bills and I'm willing to
bet that the applications that you work
on are made up of a bunch of different
components or widgets because that's the
architecture of most modern web apps the
application I work on follows the same
pattern but it does something unique as
well it actually makes a bunch of
different data requests for each of
those components so much so that we
often run into this issue where a Java
Script is single threaded right and so
what happens if you're making a lot of
requests or having to do a lot of
processing on that data on that single
thread well frequently this you get
loading spinners that are just trolling
around and around and around and then if
they keep going for long enough they
just stop your site freezes and then
maybe it totally crashes altogether and
your users are getting frustrated and
angry and then sometimes they generate
quit right but I wish that this was an
uncommon problem but it's so prevalent
that there's basically an entire
sub-genre
of internet meme devoted to talking
about slow web sites now I realized that
web performance is a very complicated
topic and I'm by no means an expert on
every facet of it but there's one part
that I find particularly interesting and
is going to be the focus of this talk
today and that is how do we ensure that
numerous large and or slow data requests
are not impacting the experiences of our
users and there are many approaches to
answering this question but one that we
found particularly helpful in the
application that I work on is to use web
workers web workers allow us to handle
data or data requests process data and
even just sit there and wait for slow
servers all
whatever blocking them browsers main
thread which leads to a better
experience for our users and that's
wonderful
but they're not exactly the easiest
construct to work with their API doesn't
follow the same patterns that most
modern web frameworks use which can make
it a bit challenging
so in short they help us out but they
also complicate things a little bit and
so today what I want to talk about is
how we can weave together webs of web
workers and what I mean by that is I
want to discuss some patterns and
strategies that we can apply to make
working with web workers easier so that
way we can maintain our code bases over
the long haul while still delivering a
great experience to our users now as was
mentioned before my name is Trent Willis
and I'm a senior UI engineer at Netflix
where I work on internal tools and we
deal with a lot of data like Netflix
scale data it's tremendous and this
little guy it's called Spidey and he's
going to be popping up throughout the
presentation today to help highlight an
underscore points that I think are
important things that you should
probably remember and take away from
this talk so let's start from the very
basics what is the web workers API the
web workers API allows web applications
to spawn background worker processes
running in parallel to their main page
in essence it brings multi-threading to
the web and this is a really really
powerful concept except interestingly
the API is not that verbose it's pretty
limited
you start by simply creating a web
worker using the worker constructor and
you give it a file path to load calling
this will create what's known as a
dedicated worker that stands in contrast
to a shared worker which will actually
be able to be used by more than one page
a normal worker can only be used by one
page at a time and so we're going to
focus on those today because they're a
bit more common and a bit simpler to
understand now the interesting thing is
when you load up a worker like this it's
going to load that script at that file
path you gave it into a new thread and
so you can actually think of them as
kind of like script tags except for
loading another JavaScript file into the
browser's main thread it's loading it
into a new thread
so that's awesome this is all you need
to do to run some JavaScript and a web
worker but that's not very helpful right
because your application your users
experience is actually all running in
the main thread so you need some way to
communicate between the two of them and
so the spec allows for workers to
communicate with the thread with the
browser's main thread through a message
passing mechanism which are basically
just like events if you've ever worked
with native JavaScript events and so for
those of you that might not be familiar
with that or might not totally
understand what that means we're going
to walk through a quick example so in
the main thread we have our worker that
we just created and on that worker we
can call a method called post message
and you can pass in some data that data
can be basically any JavaScript object
with a few exceptions most notably you
cannot pass functions what you can and
cannot pass is governed by what is known
as the structured clone algorithm in
essence what this does is it clones the
object from the main thread and
recreates it in the worker thread for
you and so once you have sent that data
in you can then focus on the worker side
of things and in your worker you have
access to a global object called self
you can essentially think of this as the
window object for your reward web worker
and on that object you are going to want
to add an event listener and you listen
for message of ents and then any time
you get an event you will have the data
that was passed in available under a
data property it's pretty
straightforward
and at this point you can do whatever
the heck you want with this data it is
now in a separate thread and it will not
impact your users experience in any
manner and so that's awesome and
whenever you're done with that data or
you want to send an update back to the
main thread you simply call post message
on the self object this works exactly
like the other post message method
except it goes in the opposite direction
and so you can probably guess how we
then get that event we add an event
listener on to the worker object and
then same as before you access the data
under the events data property now
honestly that's pretty much it in terms
of the common web worker API is that you
to run into the only earlier the only
other one that might be worth mentioning
for this talk is the terminate method
which as you might guess terminates a
worker instance it frees up all the
computing resources that have been
allocated to it and so if you're no
longer going to use a web worker call
terminate because they will run
indefinitely otherwise so if the worker
API is so simple it's so minimal then
how does it cause problems why does it
complicate things well there are four
main issues that I see developers
encounter when they start trying to use
web workers the first one is knowing
when a task is complete right you
initiate a task in your worker by
posting a message to it but you then get
updates or know when that task is
complete by receiving just generic
message events and so if you start
having multiple different tasks that are
being performed or getting multiple
different types of update messages it
quickly becomes kind of hard to know
when the thing you're interested in is
actually finished furthermore this gets
even worse if you have multiple worker
instances going at once you have all
these different workers different types
of messages being passed around and if
you want to chain some of those events
together you quickly wind up with this
tangled ball of spaghetti code and it
becomes really hard to debug and trust
me I have experienced this firsthand and
unfortunately this is all only
compounded by the fact that workers are
kind of difficult to test they don't
follow a lot of the same patterns that
we're used to using when testing other
types of code because you literally have
to context switch between different
threads in the browser
and finally there's no way to
dynamically define workers and so if
your build system isn't set up such that
you can easily split out separate
JavaScript files to load up into the
workers you're gonna run into some
issues so that's that for the four main
problems I see developers encounter when
working with web workers and I actually
think that this is hindering their
adoption somewhat but there are
solutions to all these problems they're
solvable by building on top of the tools
that the web platform is already giving
us so let's talk about those so for our
first problem knowing when a task is
complete the web platform actually
already has a built in feature that lets
us know when things
done and if you can guess what it is
it's pretty common its promises our
strategy here should be to turn those
message events into promises that way we
no longer have to worry about invoking
and finding out when our task is
complete in separate areas of our code
instead we can kind of encapsulate them
we can write a helper function like this
post message helper that actually takes
in a worker and a message gives you back
a promise and says hey I'll send this
data to the worker and when I get a
message back I'll resolve it for you and
then you can start to use it like this
and you get your invocation and your
resolution of that task all in will mine
and this becomes even nicer if you use
the async/await syntax because it makes
it look synchronous and a lot easier to
reason about and so the helper that I
just showed a little bit ago is a kind
of naive version of this library called
promise worker from Nolan Lawson it's
really great and if you want to start
using web workers I would recommend you
use a strategy like this but if we move
on to our second problem how do we then
manage and coordinate with out it
tangling up our code base well again use
promises as shown it automatically
reduces a lot of the complicated stuff
that we normally have to set up but
further than that start using methods
that look like normal functions in the
main thread and what I mean by that is
provide an abstraction that more or less
looks like any other JavaScript class or
function that you're interacting with in
your application and then you can just
apply the same strategies and patterns
that you're using throughout the rest of
your code base so as a quick example of
what I mean by that let's look at an
example where we have three workers our
first two workers are focused on making
back-end data requests they fetch the
data and then do some processing on it
and so if we write a class around our
worker we want to expose a fetch method
and then once those have returned we
want to pass that data to our third
worker which does some processing on it
in that case we want to expose a method
called process the goal here is to
reduce the amount of coordination
between all those message handlers we
had as well as
making our coat more clean and readable
and easier to understand and honestly
you wouldn't even be able to tell that
this code is running in webworkers if it
wasn't for the names of these objects
right hate a good abstraction for your
web workers should look like pretty much
every other part of your codebase except
for their methods will always be async
and this is such a huge improvement over
the default messaging interface Alec I
think there's no reason to even try to
use the other method and so I would
highly recommend you check out this
library called worker eyes from Jason
Miller or develop it
he created pre-act and this library will
take an es module that you've already
defined create a worker from it and then
give you back a promise based API to
invoke its methods by on the main thread
it's really awesome so onto our third
problem how do we dynamically define
workers this one interestingly has a
kind of widely known solution at least
in terms of web worker things and that
is you create a worker from a blob URL
of a function now if you're like me
you're like what the heck is a blob or
it's been a long time since I've seen
one of those a blob is really just a
file like object in JavaScript that
represents some data that data can be a
string and if your string happens to
contain some JavaScript code that means
you have a file like object of
JavaScript code and so you can turn that
blob into a temporary URL and then load
it into your worker Louis and voila you
have dynamic web workers that's awesome
right but remembering this whole song
and dance and how to wire it up is kind
of annoying and so you can use another
another library called Greenland which
is actually just a subset of the
functionality that worker ice provides
so again it's developed by Jason and all
you do is give it a function and I'll
give you back a promise based function
to use in return so at this point we've
talked about three of the problems that
I mentioned we have one more and that is
testing and we'll get to that in a bit
but before we do I want to talk a little
bit about an app that uses these in real
life these strategies and that is that
that I work on at Netflix called lumen
lumen is a self-service custom
dashboarding application we let users
create their own custom dash
by defining some JSON configurations and
then small custom JavaScript functions
to transform their data now you can find
more out more about it at the Netflix
tech blog but for now all you really
need to know is that for each of these
visualizations that you see there's the
possibility that they have their own
custom back-end data source they're
connecting two or even multiple and AH
as application developers have no idea
what the characteristics of that API
might be and so we process all those
requests all those data sources in web
workers to make sure it doesn't block
the main thread and we let them run
their custom transform functions inside
web workers as well by dynamically
defining them in short lumen performs
almost all of its major data operations
inside web workers this allows us to
keep the main thread free for user
interactions so they can keep clicking
on stuff scrolling no matter what data
sources or custom transformations
they're having to actually perform so
this is a real-world really critical
application that uses most of the
techniques that I've talked about so far
and before getting into talking about
testing we're going to detour a little
further and talk about some more
complicated things that you can do with
web workers because a lot of what I've
said so far is kind of basic honestly so
we're going to talk about worker to
worker communication and this is
actually what inspired the title of this
talk because you can weave together a
huge network of web workers by
communicating between them now why might
you want to do this well the reason is
because sometimes you have a lot of work
that could be subdivided or maybe you
have many small tasks and web workers
are still single threaded so it'd be
nice if you could you know spread that
work out a little bit if you want and so
there are two strategies to accomplish
this the first is to simply create
another web worker inside your web
worker and you can just reuse the
strategies we've already talked about
which is pretty great but that means
that your web worker is then having to
manage all these other relationships and
sometimes that's not great and it makes
things hard to reason about so there's a
second strategy that you can employ and
that is to actually use what's known as
a message channel a message channel
consists
of two message ports and essentially
what they are
what message ports are are just event
emitters and event receivers they're
kind of like the post message method
that you saw on the main thread and in
your worker except for they're not bound
to a specific object or a specific
context so how does this work well if we
have two workers on our main thread we
want to send messages between them we
create a new message channel we can then
take that channel take the ports on it
and post those into our web workers now
this moment you might stop and say but
wait didn't you say that we can't send
functions to workers how are they going
to be able to transfer data between each
other well you'll notice that we're
passing them as a second parameter here
actually and this parameter allows you
to specify an array of transferable
objects to post and so a transferable
represents an object that can be
transferred between different execution
contexts like the main thread and web
workers so this is a very not widely
used interface but applies to message
ports and in essence what it does is it
doesn't copy them when they're going to
a web worker but actually transfers the
object and so when you post a port into
your web worker you can no longer use it
from the main thread instead you can
only use it from the new context that it
is in unless you transfer it again and
so inside our worker when we receive
that event we can check to see if it has
ports associated with it and if it does
we can take that port and set up an
on-message Handler and a post and then
we can call post message and then that
data will go to wherever the other port
is located it provides a nice decoupling
between the web workers having to know
about each other so this whole song and
dance is kind of convoluted but it gives
us a lot of power for instance remember
this example that I gave a little bit
ago well we can actually use message
channels such that once the back-end
workers have fetched their data they
just pipe it directly to that processing
worker it never has to touch the main
thread so you can set up some really
powerful but also really complex and
essentially even really complicated
processes that never touch the main
thread using these strategies but that's
not all that you can do here we can go
even further such as we can use these
strategies to render some non-blocking
canvas graphics using the off-screen
canvas API now this is a standards API
but isn't widely implemented yet it's
available in Chrome and behind a feature
flag in Firefox but essentially it lets
you render stuff to a canvas context
like you would in the main thread but
inside a web worker so you're out of the
way of your users interactions but we
can go even further than that some folks
over at Google have been working on
actually allowing you to do non blocking
Dom manipulations you can perform some
Dom operations without having to touch
the main thread and so folks on the amp
project at Google have been working on
this library called worker Dom and it's
pretty awesome and very experimental but
the idea is wonderful right what if you
could do all of the computations and
react in the virtual DOM and all that
stuff inside your web worker you no
longer get in the way of the users and
then when you're done computing that
stuff you just transfer it back and then
quickly render it this would be
incredible so imagine this future right
you're able to fetch data you can
process it you could generate some
lovely art or images from it and then
render your application all without ever
having to touch the browser's main
thread so if your user is currently
looking at something that can keep on
scrolling keep on interacting and
they'll never notice so as an example of
kind of putting these concepts into play
I put together a small demo of Conway's
Game of Life for those not familiar
Conway's Game of Life is a quote-unquote
zero player game where essentially you
start with some inputs and then allow it
to evolve over time according to some
set of rules and so on this first demo I
put together all of this is all these
computations are being done on the main
thread and it's really janky like the
animations in the background are slow
when you click the button it does an
increment right away and so this is just
it's not a good experience but if we
move all this stuff into a web worker
and use the message channels in the
off-screen canvas API you can keep on
interacting with it even while it does
these heavy compute
patience and it's super smooth anyway
the whole point of all this is that you
can do a lot of stuff with web workers
and more is coming down the pipe so it's
awesome to start experimenting and
playing with this stuff today
but we're still left with one problem
and that is how do we test them right
well hopefully you can kind of piece it
together now right if most of our
strategies are to treat them all as
functions we're kind of left with two
strategies now the first is to start
running your testing framework in your
worker in the same thread and I actually
don't think this is a good strategy but
I have seen plenty of people try it in
essence what this means is you know
either load your worker as part of a
script tag and then run it like
basically most of your other JavaScript
code or you do it in a worker thread and
try to load your testing frameworks into
the worker thread using the import
scripts API which we haven't talked
about but isn't really important for
this talk both of these are not great
approaches in my opinion because this is
not how you are using your workers in
your application so what should you do
instead instead treat your worker as a
function or a class but oftentimes
they're kind of like functions right we
have some inputs which are messages and
we get some outputs back which are also
messages and so if you combine that idea
with these patterns that we've talked
about of turning your worker
interactions into promises it becomes
much easier to write just normal
function based unit tests so your test
start looking a lot like this all right
it's just like you have your worker
instance you have some data and then you
post message that data and then you wait
for a response to come back it's pretty
straightforward
but there is a set of caveats to this
mainly how do we mock or stub external
calls in a worker if your web workers
making calls to an external database or
an external server you don't want those
running in a unit test you need to be
able to stub that out to mock it out and
unfortunately this isn't an easy thing
to do so I made a package to help with
it it's called worker box essentially it
allows you to inject some code into an
already defined worker so that you can
properly stub or
or make any other modifications that you
need in order to properly test that web
worker now unfortunately I know this
name is actually very similar to the
Service Worker package called work box
but I named this before I was aware of
that and I don't really want to change
it now so now there's a lot more that I
could talk or say about testing but
really that's the gist of it anything
any other advice I have would kind of be
just generic testing advice and so if
you want some examples or demos to play
around with you can take a look at the
test that I actually wrote for that game
of life demo at the same glitch URL and
then just add slash tests at the end of
it so just apply the patterns that we've
talked about so far and then write your
unit tests and then if you need to mock
some stuff out try using worker box so
that brings us to the end of this talk I
hope by now you've seen that web workers
are powerful they enable us to do some
really incredible things they'd let us
get so much work off the main thread and
out of our users way but you should
probably avoid using them directly
they're not exactly the easiest thing to
work with and they can make your
codebase really difficult to maintain
over time instead stand on the shoulders
of giants look at the patterns that
others have used before and have found
success in use libraries that make it
easier to work with web workers apply
these in your application wherever it
makes sense so there's no better time
really to get started with web workers
than today I do not see them nearly
frequently enough I think in Web Apps
and so if you could apply some of the
stuff you've learned today I would be
tremendously happy that's all for me
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]